as China swelters in record high summer
temperatures U.S climate Envoy John
Kerry began talks in Beijing with
China's top official on the issue gen
Hua Kerry says it's imperative the U.S
and China make progress on addressing
the climate crisis the two countries are
the world's biggest producers of
greenhouse gases they both have the good
side of their energy transition story
which is the rapid deployment of
renewable energy and other clean
Technologies if you look at China you
know the country has been the largest
manufacturer investor and deployer of
Windows solar energy but at the same
time both countries are also heavily
addicted to fossil fuel the two sides
will discuss reducing emissions
including methane gas which contributes
to around 30 percent of global warming
curbing deforestation and the burning of
coal China has pledged to reduce its
consumption but not until 2026 new Core
Power project approvals have accelerated
since last year John Kerry's visit comes
during heightened tensions between the
U.S and China on a range of issues
including trade Taiwan and the war in
Ukraine analysts say both must set aside
differences to work together on climate
change and set a positive example ahead
of the cop 28 conference in Dubai later
this year the climate crisis is
inescapable at this point in time you
look at China you look at you know the
rest of the war the summer that we're
having where I should say the summer
that we're suffering across the world I
hope this really drives the message of
climate urgency Beijing says its climate
cooperation with Washington is generally
good but there are sticking points China
accuses the US of unfairly criticizing
its climate record while failing to meet
its own pledges including financing
developing countries Kerry is the third
high-level U.S official to visit in
recent weeks aging hopes his arrival
will not only stop the world overheating
but also the U.S China relationship
Katrina Al Jazeera Beijing
more than 55 million